okay let's get started
let's uh get started on the topic for
today
so
today we're going to be talking about
non-parametric few shot learning this
will also be part of your second
homework assignment we'll talk about a
few different methods for this and what
even what non-parametric future learning
even is
and then we'll also go over a case study
of applying a form of non-parametric
fuchsia learner to
a medical image diagnosis problem
after that we'll talk about some
properties of meta-learning algorithms
that are desirable and will compare
different the three different classes of
approaches we've talked about so far
with respect to those desirable
properties
and then we'll also go over a few metal
learning applications including
imitation learning drug discovery motion
prediction and language generation and
cover some of the ways that people have
applied ideas and metal learning to
various problems
uh and then by the end of the lecture
hopefully you'll be able to understand
non-parametric feature learning
techniques as well as how to implement
them
which will be helpful for your second
homework you'll um we'll go over kind of
the trade-offs between different kinds
of methods and then also i hope to
help you give you some familiarity with
different applied formulations of med
learning as well
okay so that's the plan for today uh and
before we kind of talk about
non-parametric view shot learning i want
to just briefly recap the two classes of
metal earning approaches that we've
talked about so far
so
last week we first
talked about black box metal learning
and the key idea with a black box metal
learner is that you have some set of
training data points that's going to be
fed into
a black box neural network such as a
recurrent neural network f theta
and
you'll also additionally pass in a new
unlabeled test input and
train this entire learner to be able to
correctly predict the corresponding
label
and this is also the kind of metal order
that you've been implementing in
homework one
and the
benefits of this is very expressive the
downside is it's a very challenging
opposition problem which you may have
encountered in the homework as well
next on wednesday last week we talked
about optimization based meta learning
which
embeds an optimization inside this meta
learning process and then you can differ
then you can differentiate and optimize
things such as the initialization of
that optimization process the learning
rate and other free parameters of the
optimization
and uh this is uh the main benefit of
this kind of method is that it builds in
the structure of optimization into the
meta learning process
which can make it easier to optimize and
also easier to generalize to tasks
outside of your task distribution
uh the downside is that it typically
requires a second order optimization
which may be
computationally expensive
okay so these are the two
metal learning algorithms that we've
talked about so far
and what we want to talk about what
we're going to talk about today is if we
can embed a learning procedure
into the meddler
without requiring a second order
optimization
and in particular so far we've been
thinking about learning parametric
models and and
kind of parametric approaches approaches
to learning
but when you're in a low data regime
non-parametric methods
are simple and they actually work quite
well in low data regime
so for example things like nearest
neighbors
is an example of a non-parametric
approach to to learning
where you have some data and you take
whatever kind of
training data point is closest to your
test data point you output the
corresponding classification and there
are of course variants such as k-nearest
neighbors and so forth
and
one kind of critical thing to note is
that in the kind of fu shot metal
learning problem that we've been talking
about at meta test time fu shot learning
is exactly in the low data regime
so kind of
with this in mind we want to think about
how we might leverage non-parametric
methods in the inner loop
however during metatrading we still want
to be parametric because we want to be
able to leverage a large amount of
previous experience and data
so one of the key
key tradeoffs between parametric and
non-parametric methods is that
non-parametric methods are simple and
work well in data regime but when you
have a ton of data
they don't scale as well because you
have to kind of do lookups on your
entire on your training data set
and so that's why it kind of
when we're doing fuchsia learning at
meta test time
we're going to look at being in a
non-parametric setting and during meta
training we're going to try to be in the
parametric setting
uh and a particular kind of the key idea
is whether we can use parametric metal
learners that produce effective
non-parametric learners
so that's the motivation here uh do you
have a question
yeah can you please recap as in what is
parametric and what is non-parametric
learner
yeah so a parametric learner is a
setting where you are um you're learning
a model a parametric model that has
parameters uh hence the name parametric
that uh for example like a classifier
that takes as input an input and
produces
an output and in non-parametric methods
like nearest neighbors and k nearest
neighbors
there's no
parameters involved uh
because
and essentially kind of your your
training data points are kind of like
your parameters your data is like your
parameters so
in this diagram which is showing an
example of nearest neighbors
each of these blue and red points are
the data points in your data set
and whatever you want to classify a new
data point you basically
uh just look at the color of that
corresponding spot so if your new data
point is somewhere over here then it
would be blue because the nearest data
point is blue if you're somewhere over
here then you would output
the label red because the nearest data
points are red
and in this sort of approach there's
kind of no
parameters
which is kind of why they're called
non-parametric methods
okay
cool and i guess it's also worth noting
that some of the methods that we'll be
covering today actually precede some of
the parametric approaches to metal
learning
okay so how do we actually do this and
what does this actually look like in the
future learning setting so if you were
to take our
classic like fuchsia image
classification problem
and apply to non-parametric learning
technique like nearest neighbors what we
would do is we would take our test data
point and compare it to each of
the trading
points
in our trades
and then
find the nearest neighbor and output the
label corresponding to the nearest
neighbor so if this image was the
nearest neighbor then we would output
the class corresponding to this image if
this one was the nearest neighbor we
output the other corresponding class
now
uh
so the idea is that we're going to be
comparing our test image with our
training images
now an important question here is in
kind of in what space do you compare and
with what distance metric do you compare
so one kind of very naive and simple
idea that we might do is maybe do like
l2 distance in pixel space to compare
images and that's what like a typical
kind of naive nearest neighbors approach
would do
but unfortunately this is a pretty bad
idea so for example
uh this is a
example from this paper by richard zhang
adolf where if you took this image and
compared it to these two images
you would think intuitively that it
should be closer to this image just
because that kind of perceptually looks
more similar but if you actually compute
the l2 distance between these two images
it turns out that this one is actually
closer in l2 distance than this one
um so this suggests that this is kind of
one anecdotal
example of why l2 distance might be a
bad idea
okay um so what might we do instead of
doing
pixel space or l2 distance
uh does anyone have any
ideas or or thoughts or
um thoughts on on what we might do
to get a good distance metric
you can raise your hand or enter it and
chat
uh yeah maybe you can learn some sort of
um embedding heuristic and then
um i guess sort of like like features
that already be extracted like a cnn and
use that like embedding in a feature
space to compare
yeah so one thing you could do is
instead of doing like distance in the
original space you could do it in some
embedding space
uh and this will uh likely produce kind
of much better uh a much better distance
metric if that embedding reflects kind
of more the semantics of these images uh
any thoughts on where you might get that
embedding
either from from someone else
a professor
yeah
so uh maybe i'm thinking we can take a
pre-trained model for example like the
image net preaching resin 50 and take
maybe the first layer or second hidden
layer and just to fit through the image
that i want to compare and take out the
like second or some intermediate hidden
layers and use that as embed
yeah so you could basically train a
model on imagenet and use the kind of
embeddings produced by image.nearest
neighbors in that space
so that's kind of one um
one way that you could get such a
bettings are there any ideas for
how you might kind of use a metal
learning-like approach to get an
embedding
or a distance metric
um perhaps you could have a model which
uh
feeds over each of the images and
produces some embedding you perform the
the distance measure over that embedding
and then the loss is used to train
that models uh the embedding that it
produces
yeah so this i think that you're kind of
getting at getting at the right idea uh
does anyone want to elaborate on that
maybe
i'm thinking we can change to directly
predict whether two images belongs to
the same
class for the output would be directly
the
distance magic
yeah so that's actually the first
approach that we'll talk about which is
that you can basically train and train
something to compare images and tell you
whether or not those images are from the
same class
and so
we can basically use the meta training
data and learn this comparator that
tells us if something is the same or not
so
what this looks like is for example you
could train a siamese network to predict
whether two images are of the same class
what this would look like is you take
two images
you pass that through
a network to produce uh kind of an
embedding and then you have kind of an
additional set of layers that output
whether or not
they are the same class or not so for
this pair you would train it to output
zero because they're a different
class for this pair of images you would
tell it to output one because these both
correspond whoops to the class of bowls
looks like this slide isn't advancing
one
um yeah so in this case you would have
to try to output one
in this case you would try it out but
zero
in this case you would train to output
one and so forth
so essentially you're kind of training a
network with your metatrading data to
tell you whether or not two images are
from the same class
and then at meta test time when you want
to predict the label what you can do is
you can compare
each um you can pair your x test image
to each of the images in d train
and
predict the one that has break the label
corresponding to the image that has the
highest probability of corresponding to
the same class as your test image
cool
um so this is kind of like the first
this was actually an approach uh
proposed in 2015 and it was really one
of the first approaches to using uh
neural networks in the context of flu
shot learning
any questions on that i feel like i'm
also behind on
on the chat
i think the chat was mostly thinking
about questions from our answers to the
previous questions so do you have a
question
um yes so
when we're thinking about non-parametric
um because neural network has like
parameters is that like
uh
kind of like not counted in this case
like uh
maybe it's okay
i was a bit confused
yeah so i guess i'm calling this kind of
a class of non-parametric
methods or learners in the sense that
there are actually parameters uh and
these parameters are actually trained
with the meta training set
um
i guess it's uh
i like to call it a kind of a
non-parametric method in the sense that
it really resembles a lot of the
non-parametric methods that we have in
machine learning like nearest neighbors
um k near savers and so forth because
uh because we are kind of just looking
at the images and literally like in this
case literally doing nearest neighbors
but according to this metal learned
metric of whether or not two images are
the same
so essentially you can view it as like a
parametric metal learner uh that's kind
of telling you
giving you a metric under which to
compare images
and then once you have this metric
you're using kind of a non-parametric
approach to
predict the label for the test input
okay so the non-parametric aspect of it
is where we actually predict it
from
just like this final level
of space yeah yeah so you can sort of
view it as like the inner loop being
non-parametric and the outer loop being
parametric uh of course the the model
that the outer loop produces is used in
the inner loop
so it
potentially could be viewed as like a
semi-parametric approach but i think you
i think you have the idea
okay cool thanks
yeah and so
um
asking the distance layer uses a
specific metric or does it learn metrics
from the training data um so in this
case this network here which is
essentially kind of learning
um
learning a sort of metric although it
may not kind of obey the triangle
inequality but in any case it's learning
something that makes comparisons between
these two images
and we train this network using all of
the meta training data all of the image
classes in our metatrading data and then
when we're given new image classes we
can still expect this model to
generalize because it's simply telling
you for a new pair of images whether
they're the same class
um
and you follow this kind of procedure
down here to make a prediction for x
test at meta test time
okay
uh so this is kind of the key idea um
behind this initial approach
now
one um
in general this approach
works pretty well and it's quite simple
which is really nice
but one downside of this approach is
that during metatrading time you're
basically training it for this binary
classification problem of whether or not
these two images are
the same class
but at meta test time you're doing this
n-way classification where you're
comparing the images
the test image to all of the images in
the training data set and outputting the
corresponding label within the n classes
and so we have this discrepancy between
what we're meditating for and what we're
meta-testing for
so
one thing that we would like to do to
improve this approach is to try to match
what's happening at metatrading time
and
meta-testing time
so
this is kind of the the key idea behind
this work called matching networks
and
essentially uh you could view it as
learning an embedding space and doing
nearest neighbors in this in that
embedding space and then optimizing for
a model such that
nearest neighbors output's the correct
answer
so what this looks like is something
like this where all the images on the
left are the training data points for
your task
and this is the test input x test
you pass all of these examples in
you basically get embeddings for each of
your training examples you also get an
embedding for your test example
and
then this uh operation
computes
something like the kind of negative
distance between your test embedding and
each of your training embeddings
and then once you have
compared these and
kind of have an estimate for
which
which of these is the most similar to
your test example you then use this to
use this estimate and dot product it
with the labels of each of your training
examples to produce the corresponding
label so for example in this one
when you compare
the embedding of the dog here and the
betting of the test example it finds
that that is kind of has the highest
weight or is the most likely
to to match and then
when you take the dot product it will
output the corresponding label for that
dog because that has the or for the red
label because that has the closest image
so kind of mathematically what this
looks like is you can
view each of these
black dots as
this function that tells you
the similarity between x tests in each
of your training examples xk
these are each of the labels yk for each
of your
trading examples
and then your output y hat test is
basically equal to the uh
the
kind of
dot product between
your similarities and your
labels
so you can essentially view these
similarities as probabilities over which
example it thinks it is
and
once you take these probabilities and
output by the corresponding label you
then get a probability distribution over
what you think is the label for this
test example
cool um and then i guess i don't want to
go into the architecture too much but a
couple kind of uh general things about
this architecture is that
it uses a convolutional encoder to embed
the images into these vectors
um and for the embeddings of the
training examples it actually isn't just
a feed-forward model they actually use a
bi-directional lstm
so the embedding of each example is
actually also affected by the other
images in the um
in the training data set and this whole
architecture is trained
and and with respect to the accuracy on
your test example
okay uh do you have a question
yeah so for the embedding do you need to
use a pre-trained model or this is
trained end-to-end
it's all trained end-to-end uh you could
kind of pre-trade some of these modules
with like imagenet or something um but
all of it is trained end to end with
respect to the future classification
prediction here
it also looks like there's a question in
the chat
saying how is h theta and g theta
related um i think that they're just
kind of denoting these as
the basically
um theta are the parameters of the
entire metal learner and these are just
kind of two completely separate models
um that use different parts of theta to
make their corresponding prediction
do you have a question
uh yeah i just want to know in the geo
theta part which which network comes
first the lstm comes first for the cnn
uh i think it's a convoluted i think
they first kind of uh use a cnn and then
they do a bi-directional lstm on top of
what the convolution layers produce
you can check the paper for
details information behind this
um yeah so lstms typically
operate on like kind of low dimensional
vectors um and so if you
took like the standard lstm and applied
it on top of the images you actually
need to flatten the images before
passing it into the lcm which wouldn't
leverage the spatial structure of the
image
uh so that's kind of one reason why it
may make sense to put the convolutions
first that said there is an architecture
uh there's kind of a version of an lcm
called a convelustm that basically
replaces all replaces all the matrix
multiplies with convolution operations
and you could imagine doing something
like that um instead of doing
convolution and then let's jam
thank you
okay
yeah this looks a lot like um an
attention mechanism in a lot of ways i'm
curious how well in practice this really
generalizes to unseen data um how much
it's just learning things like for this
example
um features and dedicated dogs
yeah um
let's see so it does actually draw a lot
of similarities to attention this was
back in 2016 and i don't even know
if attention had really been uh really
thoroughly defined or wasn't very
popular at least at that point um and
maybe if this paper was introduced today
they would have called it something more
like attention uh this operation right
here certainly in particular looks a lot
like attention because you're kind of
comparing um comparing the embedding to
each of the other embeddings
um in general it does actually
generalize these kinds of architectures
do actually usually generalize pretty
well um
in practice uh
i think because of kind of the structure
that's built in we'll also introduce one
more approach that builds upon this
idea um that is kind of one of the more
i think de facto models in in kind of
the non-parametric q shock
classification realm
it also looks like asking are h3 and g
theta the same network are different
these are kind of different networks
and this particular is just kind of a
feed forward feed forward convolution
model
uh and this model is a bi-directional
lcm i think that
there are some weights between this
convolutional encoder and um and kind of
the encoder of this one but i'm i can't
remember exactly you can check the paper
for details
okay
cool and then it is asking what are the
drawbacks of letting them share the same
network
uh
i think that
there are benefits to parameter sharing
in general because it may increase the
efficiency
um
it may also be that it's helpful to have
a different encoder
for the training examples and for the
test examples for things like edge
detectors then parameter sharing makes a
lot of sense but maybe there's some
other features that may want to encode
differently in the training examples in
the test example
i'll take one more question from
um hi so is this still going to be
trained in like a tool um
process where you back properly the
performance on the meta testing or like
the the
query
yeah so basically you'll see you'll
still well we'll go over the full
procedure but you will back propagate
and trade all of this with respect to
how accurate
why test why hat test is basically how
accurate is able to it's able to
classify this test image
cool thanks
cool and then i guess one thing to
highlight here is unlike siamese
networks
now metatrading and meta testing match
because you're actually meditating it
for
kind of n-way
classification where assignments
networks is just training it for
two-way classification
uh what the algorithm looks like is is
basically pretty similar to
the
kind of general framework that we've
gone through before
what's going to be a bit different is
instead of computing these parameters
we're going to be computing the
prediction for the test input
uh this kind of illustrates how it's
somewhat of a non-parametric approach
we're not actually computing any
parameters of any model
you compute the prediction on the test
input
uh you can also view this as having the
parameters sort of integrated out
and then we'll update the
kind of meta parameters of this overall
model using the
prediction error on your test inputs
okay
great so this is uh this is
what we just talked about is called
matching networks it's a pretty popular
approach
for fu shot learning
now
when we think about kind of one more
approach that builds upon this
uh
one important question to think about is
what if you have more than one shot what
if you have more than one example per
class
uh and in particular if we go back to
this architecture
does anyone have any ideas for like
what you might do
with this architecture or kind of how
this architecture handles the case where
you have more than one example per class
so maybe you have two dogs of this breed
for example how how do you think that
this model handles that case
is asking take the sum of all examples
so one thing that you could do is uh
is instead of so basically when you have
two examples of this dog this embedding
for example you could have just kind of
one embedding for
that kind of breed
this is actually hinting at what we'll
talk about in the next approach
um
in this matching networks paper though
the kind of the way that they handled
the setting where you had more than one
examples is it just treated them
completely independently so it just took
if you had two examples of this other
dog it would also pass that kind of
the example of that dog breed create
another embedding vector for that dog
breed so it had two embeddings for that
label and then we added kind of an
additional label here
it would basically treat them like
independently almost as if they were
different classes
uh so this is kind of the approach that
that thing is mentioning where you just
basically feed all the images in and
also
feed all the corresponding labels and
you don't do anything special to
aggregate information across the class
um
and this is kind of potentially a bit of
a downside because it doesn't really
aggregate class information
across images and
the aggregated information may be more
useful because maybe kind of the test
examples you'll see may have features
present in one example and some features
present in another example and if you
don't aggregate that that information it
may not be able to accurately predict
the the label for that uh that test
example
um and so this is kind of the key idea
behind what's called prototypical
networks and what it does is each of
these colored dots corresponds to
the different examples in d train
embedded into a kind of a low
dimensional space
and instead of treating kind of these
examples completely independently which
is what matching networks would do
it takes the average of those of all the
examples of the same class
and then when it does nearest neighbors
instead of doing nearest neighbors to
kind of each of these it does nearest
neighbors to the prototypical embedding
of each of those classes
so all these green examples correspond
to c1 all the blue examples correspond
to c3 and so forth and you average the
average the embeddings to create a kind
of a prototypical embedding for that
class and then do nearest neighbors with
regard to the prototypical embedding
uh so mathematically what this looks
like is
you compute each of these centroids
uh cn
by averaging
all of the embeddings
for the data points in
that class
basically for all the embeddings with
the label equal to n
and then when you want to compute the
label for a new test input x
you then
look at the distance between your test
example and each of these centroids
and then to get a probability you
exponentiate the negative distance and
then normalize
okay and then this distance function d
it could be in this paper they looked at
a euclidean distance or a cosine
distance there are other kind of metrics
that you could use as well
crucially though this distance metric is
inside this embedding space it's not in
the original space
okay any questions on how this works
do you have a question or is your hand
up from before
okay sounds good i'll take that as that
was clear hopefully
what's your question
yeah i'm just curious about how this
method compared to previous methods
yeah
normal parametric message
yeah so
this model was able to show improvements
over matching networks uh particularly
in the case where you have more than one
shot if you only have one shot then they
are basically the same
because the embedding will be
the the same as kind of
it'll just be the kind of that one
example is embedding
um it also shows improvements kind of
significant improvement both of these
both matching networks and protocol
networks show significant improvements
over assignments that worked
yeah i was just curious if people have
tried better strategies than averaging
uh
averaging the embedding from getting set
yeah
so
this kind of gets actually at my next
point which is that like maybe averaging
isn't really the best way to
way to look at things and what if you
have kind of more complex relationships
between different data points of the
same class
and there are kind of a few different
approaches that do this so for example
um
i guess this isn't really replacing the
average but this is
uh learning learning a distance in
prototypical networks rather than using
euclidean or
cosine distance or something it's
actually learning a neural network to
produce the distance
in general i think that averaging is a
reasonable choice
because oftentimes the encoder of these
embeddings
is already doing something more
sophisticated than just a feed forward
model it may already like for example if
it's a convolution if it's a
bi-directional lcm it's already taking
into account some of the differences
between these images when it produces
the embedding space
so typically just averaging i think is
pretty reasonable although you may want
to learn
one setting where averaging may not work
is if you have kind of pretty diverse
variation within a class so maybe um
for example if you're in the
uh let's see what's a good example of
this
maybe if you're kind of your class is
like is this a person or an animal maybe
kind of people look very different and
so you may want to have kind of
different representations of things or
maybe animals look very different and so
you may want to have kind of different
pro multiple prototypes for different
kinds
of a more course class
and so this paper
allows you to learn a mixture of
prototypes for each class rather than
just having a single prototype
so this is an alternative to just using
averaging
and then a third approach is to
uh kind of if you have even more complex
relationships between the different
classes
there's also another approach that uses
graph convolutions to essentially do
message passing on the embeddings where
you have a set of embeddings and then
you
pass messages kind of loosely between
those different embeddings to refine
your representation of each class
what's your question
so that it makes sense to learn the
distance embedding also when the input
has like a bimodal microphone
distribution because the average may not
be the name of
any of this
yeah so i kind of view there as being
two design choices one is
like how do you when you have a set of
embeddings for all the examples in your
class how do you choose the prototypes
and one way might be to have kind of
multiple prototypes using a mixture uh
and then the second question is like how
do you how do you kind of derive your
distance function
um and this method derives the the
learns the distance function in
prototypical networks and you could also
kind of combine these two ideas i can't
remember exactly
what distance function they used here um
it looks like it's just something like
euclidean for example with disrespect to
the each of the prototype centers
um
so i think that both of those are kind
of design choices that come up in these
methods
the third part is more like a graph
network right graph convolution
what they're learning is distance metric
here
uh and then asked in the chat
here it seems the embeddings from the
same class cluster
together is that the general case so
yeah so in the slide that i was showing
before in general they'll kind of
cluster together in your embedding space
because that's kind of the right thing
to do but in applications like the ones
right here they may not cluster together
and that in those kinds of situations if
you have a more multi-modal distribution
within a class it may make sense to have
multiple prototypes within that class
okay cool um
so
now let's move on and talk about how we
might look at this apply these methods
to a practical problem
and in particular we'll look at this
paper which uses
a variant on prototypical that works for
dermatological image classification
and this paper appeared at the machine
learning for healthcare conference in
2019 and also the nurips machine
learning for healthcare workshop in 2018
and there's also a link to the paper if
you're interested in looking at it
yourself
and the problem that they wanted to look
at was
fuchsia learning for diagnosing
different dermatological diseases
so different skin conditions
and this problem has a number of
different challenges so first it tends
to be pretty hard to get data because
the data
is
fairly personal
and also the data is quite long tailed
so there's a lot of different conditions
that are very common and there are some
skin conditions that are very rare
and then lastly there's also significant
intraclass variability so
depending on where the skin condition is
occurring on the skin
or depending on
the um kind of the skin type and so
forth you may have a lot of variability
within a single disease
and then the goal of this paper was to
try to
acquire an accurate classifier on all
classes so essentially different classes
are going to correspond to different
diseases and they want to be able to
classify which disease a condition
corresponds to
um
which disease a patch of skin
corresponds to
among all of the classes in their
training data set
and in particular they looked at the
dermnet data set uh which
is
visualized here
and in particular what this is showing
is that this is showing that only
actually only the top 200 classes
um
where you see this really long tail
distribution where for some of the
classes like eczema and acme there's a
very large number of examples with like
maybe a thousand or 500 examples
and then there's this hugely long tail
where there's many many conditions that
have
like less than 50 examples for example
uh and there are actually there's
actually more classes i think that up to
like maybe up to 600 classes total in
this data set
uh and even when you only look at the
first 200 classes you still see this
this pretty dramatic tale
uh and beyond kind of
dermatology
these sorts of long tail distributions
come up all the time so this is a
problem that's quite relevant
in practical machine learning
applications
okay so their goal was to acquire
basically a 200-way classifier
for these different diseases
and the way that they formulated this is
that different image classes correspond
to different diseases and they took 150
base classes that they're going to use
for metatrading and 50 novel classes
that they're going to hold out
and try to be able to generalize to just
from a small amount of data
uh and in particular they took the the
base classes are the ones with the most
data and the novel classes are the ones
where you only have a small number of
examples which is kind of a natural way
to split the data
and then
at a test time they wanted to get a
classifier that works can classify among
all 200 classes
so unlike the omni lot setting that
you're looking at in your homework where
you were like doing like 10 way
classification for example um here
they're actually going to be meta
training with
around kind of
uh leveraging data from
150 based classes and they actually want
a classifier that can go beyond 150 base
classes
and now one thing that's worth noting
here is that kind of unlike the
approaches that we've seen so far with
black box and optimization based pet
learning
uh
non-parametric methods can actually
train for n-way classification and test
for greater than n weight classification
because you can still compute embeddings
uh for all of the examples and you can
still do this form of nearest neighbors
or kind of nearest neighbors to the
prototypes
for more than and even if you've only
trained on n
uh so this is one of the kind of
positive features of these kinds of
approaches
uh so that means that they can actually
get a 200 way classifier after only
metatrading on a number of classes
that's less than that
so the approach they take is they take
prototypical networks and they expand on
it in two different ways so first they
learn multiple prototypes per class so
this is pretty similar to one of the
papers that i was mentioning before
where they learned a mixture of
prototypes and this allows them to
handle interclass variability
and second they also
incorporate unlabeled support examples
uh where they basically support examples
where they don't have labels for uh for
example that the test the query examples
by doing k-means on top of the learned
embedding space
uh
and this allows them to kind of leverage
these unlabeled examples to better
predict uh
better predictive queries
okay and then one side note is that if
you do decide to kind of read this paper
and look into some of the details they
actually flip the standard notation of k
and n in the paper which is a bit
confusing if you read it but once you
understand that they're flipping this
it's hopefully uh a bit easier to kind
of flip in your head if you're used to
ny and k shot classification
okay uh and then in their evaluation
they compare to standard prototypical
networks which is trained on 150 base
classes uh it's also pre-trained on
imagenet with their method they also
pre-trained uh pre-trained the protocol
clustering that works on image depth as
well
uh they also compared to
this um this kind of fine-tuning
approach where they took
an image that pre-trained model
they find tuned it on
n classes where n is varying and is
either going to be 150 or 200 and then
they ran uh one nearest neighbors or
three nearest neighbors in the resulting
and betting space
and then lastly they compared to an
imagenet pre-trained model that's
fine-tuned actually on all 200 classes
uh using balancing
and this last method is a pretty strong
baseline it accesses more information
during training than both their approach
as well as these two baselines
and also if you want to introduce new
classes into your data set it requires
like completely retraining for those new
classes
so in some ways this method is uh is a
bit privileged it has kind of
um
it has kind of more more information and
more requires more compute than the
other methods
and then they evaluated this on mean
class accuracy which is just the average
of
each of the per class accuracies
across the 200 classes
and this treats all of the classes as
equal even if some of the classes have
more data than other classes
and they kind of argued that this is a
reasonable thing to do in this setting
okay um
is asking how does the embedding
generalize on unseen classes
the
basically when you train this encoder
across 150 base classes
um you're training it to be able to like
produce embeddings that are
distinguishable within those 150 classes
and then when you're given an unseen
class
the hope is that that encoder will also
produce a distinguishable bill and
betting for a new class
and if you trade on enough uh
on enough classes you can expect
reasonable generalization assuming that
the new classes the new unseen classes
are
not like significantly far from the
distribution of images that you saw
previously
okay
so to finish up this kind of case study
these are what the results look like
so the first thing to note here is that
their method that
incorporates the unlabeled data and also
has multiple prototypes per class is
able to do significantly better than
just vanilla prototypical networks which
is nice
it does better across
both the
base classes as well as the novel
classes that are held out
second
is that their method significantly
outperforms
at least this is at least on the novel
classes so in general on the novel
classes um pcn is able to significantly
outperform
uh when you're fine-tuning then doing
nearest neighbors on the fine-tuned
embedding
uh for the base classes it does
similarly and slightly worse um although
in terms of the overall accuracy on both
base and novel it's able to do
it's able to do better than
than this kind of fine tuning nearest
neighbor's approach
and then lastly they found that their
kind of prototypical clustering networks
is able to do about as well
as this kind of strong baseline that's
fine tuning on all 200 classes even
though pcn was only kind of trained on
150 classes
uh so this is pretty nice in that
they're able to do as well as this
method without requiring retraining for
every new class that you might want to
add to this model
great and then they also have more
visual visualizations and analysis in
the paper
yeah i'm just curious to know like this
feed forward uh
this fine tuning method where the
network sees all the 200 classes my that
had like a very low performance on the
novel classes because in effect the
model has been trained on those classes
already
but the lens is like very low compared
to the base classes like if there is
some
like explanation why that might be the
case yeah so i think that
my intuition for that is that basically
when you
explicitly train for a few shot
generalization which is what meta
learning methods do in general and also
what prototypical networks and pcn does
uh you're explicitly generalizing it to
be able to produce an embedding that can
generalize even when that that kind of
prototype was produced with only a few
examples
whereas uh
it's very likely i think that this this
fine tune model is probably overfitting
when it only sees a few examples for
these novel classes
each of these novel classes have like
less than 50 examples total so
it's
probably pretty easy to overfit
and then also pcn introduces a way to
leverage unlabeled data and that may be
helping it to
perform better
than this method which isn't able to
label to leverage the unlabeled data
okay
also asking in the chat why is the mean
class accuracy low less than 50
so
uh first this is kind of a 200 way
classification problem so
random performance would be at kind of
one over 200 which is uh so it is like
substantially improving over that at
least
i also think that this task is a quite a
challenging task the amount of total
data points is
um per class is relatively low even the
most populous examples had like around a
thousand examples uh and once you get to
the novel examples you have a very very
small amount of data that it has to
learn from and so
uh that would explain why these numbers
aren't like in the 90s for example
okay
great and then there was one other
question in the chat
um which all that was about
non-parametric utah learners which is
that can they be effective for test text
classification
and yeah so the original matching
networks paper actually included
experiments on a text classification
problem so i'd encourage you to look at
the experiments in that paper if you're
interested in that
but they can be effective for text
classification is the short answer
okay so now let's talk about some of the
properties of metal learning algorithms
and compare different the three
different classes of approaches that
we've talked about so far
so we talked about black box methods
optimization based factors and
non-parametric methods
and the first way that we'll think about
comparing them is from the standpoint of
a computation graph
and we talked about this perspective
before when we were comparing black box
methods and optimization based methods
we talked about how a black box method
is basically directly producing a model
that takes this input of training data
set in a test input
and an optimization phase
could
also be viewed as this computation graph
that takes this input training data set
in a test example but one where it
involves this kind of
inner loop optimization inside that
computation graph
where essentially you run grading
descent on your training example and
then use the the resulting parameters to
make predictions on your test input
but it's still this kind of general
computation graph that takes some
footage data set in the test input
non-parametric methods can also be cast
inside this perspective of a computation
graph
where
you
have a training dataset and test input
and the way that this prediction is
produced
is
using a
uh
like basically comparing the embeddings
of your test example and your prototypes
and
each of these prototype examples is
computed using your training data set
uh it's computed using kind of the
average of all of the classes in that
in that the average of all the
embeddings in that class
so all three of these methods can
basically just be viewed as different
forms of this function f
where you
kind of pass the data set into
the model in some way either by running
gradient descent or by looking at
nearest neighbors to a prototype
orbit is passing it directly into the
model
and also all of them take as input to
test example
in some way either by passing it into
the model with updated parameters by
comparing it to the prototype or by just
passing it directly into the model
cool so this is one perspective of
thinking about the differences of these
approaches as basically just different
ways to ingest data and a test example
uh and
it's also worth noting again is that you
can mix and match different components
of the different computation graphs and
get different kinds of methods as well
so
for example there's one
uh method that both conditions on the
data in this way and run runs gradient
descent this is one valid approach
uh there's also approach that does
gradient descent on top of a relational
network embedding so it's kind of
somewhat similar to a non-parametric
approach and an optimization based
approach
uh there's also a method that runs
mammal but initializes the last layer as
a proto-net during meta
so there's kind of various ways to
design
this this function that takes his input
the training data and the test input and
you can leverage different elements of a
non-parametric learner of grading based
optimization
uh and so forth
okay
so that's the computation graph
perspective uh and then this
i'd like to provide to think about these
classes of methods is from the
standpoint of various properties that we
might want
so
one property that we might want from
these models is for them to be very
expressive to be able to process the
data in many different ways
essentially the ability for this
function f to represent a range of
learning procedures
uh and this is helpful for scalability
and applicable applicability to a wide
range of domains especially if we don't
have good ways to
do kind of optimization and learning in
that setting
the second property that i think is
desirable is something that i'll call
consistency
and the idea of consistency
is that we want the learned learning
procedure
to
be able to improve
with more data
essentially at test time
when you give it new data from a new
task
the more data you give it the better you
want it to do right that seems like a
pretty reasonable thing to ask
and ideally it would do that regardless
of the task that you're giving it and
regardless of the meta training tasks
even if this task is out of distribution
it would be nice if it can actually
improve as you give it more data
um and this will
if you have a learning procedure like
this this will reduce
the reliance on the mediterranean tasks
and it will also potentially give you
better out-of-distribution task
performance
and this is something that we can expect
when we're actually running an
optimization
at test time
okay
and you can also recall kind of the
example that we showed before when we
looked at out of distribution tests and
we saw that mammal was a bit more robust
uh i think these these two properties
are pretty important for most
applications
now how do these different approaches
fare on these two
on these two
metrics so blackbox methods have
complete expressive power if you have a
big enough recurrent neural network
but they aren't consistent so if you
give it more data and you pass in more
data into your
rnn
um at test time it may not continue to
improve there's nothing to kind of
guarantee that it's actually uh kind of
descending on some objective per se
uh optimization based methods they are
consistent uh because you're running
gradient descent in expectation you can
expect your loss to go down and
over time with gradient descent
uh and they are expressive like we
mentioned like we talked about on
wednesday although that this does
require very deep models uh in order to
get the kind of maximal expressive power
that you get with a black box starter
um and this is for the supervised
learning setting uh this actually isn't
true in the reinforcement learning
setting but it there are some details
there and we'll talk about that when we
start talking about reinforcement
learning
uh and then lastly for non-parametric
methods they are quite expressive for
most architectures that you use
um
the expressive power essentially depends
on the architecture
and they're also consistent under
certain conditions
basically as you add
more examples
uh if your metric is uh properly assigns
like zero
to
zero distance to two examples that are
the same or very similar then you could
expect giving it more training data will
lead it to be more likely to produce an
example that is very close
to
your um
to your test example
okay so that's kind of an analysis of
these three methods along those two axes
there are also a number of other pros
and cons of these methods so
um
one thing with with blockbox classes is
that they're very easy to combine with
different learning problems
but it also produces a more challenging
optimization
uh and this is i think this is getting
out of question asked in the chat which
is what is the convergence rate of
different approaches
um it's
a bit difficult to kind of theoretically
analyze the convergence rate of
different conditions especially when
you're using neural networks because we
don't it relies on a number of factors
and neural network optimization is a in
general a complex topic to analyze
but we can at least say kind of in
practice and empirically we observe that
at least for black box models we observe
that we have a more challenging
optimization and likely slower
convergence
and we can also say things about
optimization based on non-parametric
methods which we'll get to in a second
and as a result blackbox methods tend to
be data inefficient in terms of the data
that's needed for meta training
okay um for optimization based methods
we get this positive and inductive bias
at the start of metal learning by
because we are embedding an optimization
into
the
metal learner
it also handles varying
k and large k well because you can
simply average the gradient across
varying numbers of shots that you have
and it's model agnostic in the sense
that you don't have to design a
particular architecture like you do in a
black box method
and then the downside is that it
requires a second order optimization
which can require more compute and
memory
uh and then lastly with non-parametric
methods
one really nice benefit is that they're
entirely feed forward
this makes them in general kind of
computationally fast and easy to
optimize and just easy to work with in
general
the downside is that uh it's empirically
been observed that they don't generalize
to varying k
well
um although we did actually talk about
recently how they can generalize to
varying n well so they can
generalize to varying numbers of classes
but not necessarily varying amounts of
data per class
um of course if you have a very large
amount of data in the inner loop they're
going to be hard to scale because you
have to
uh you have kind of large computation
costs for nearest neighbor lookups
uh and so far these methods have been
limited to classification for the most
part
yeah and actually this gets at the at
the chat the questions that just appear
in the chat is can non-parametric
methods be used for regression
in general they haven't been
used for regression so far
okay and then lastly i'll mention that
generally well-tuned versions of these
methods generally perform comparably on
existing few shot learning benchmarks
and uh
this may say more about the benchmarks
than about the methods themselves i
think that kind of existing future image
classification benchmarks don't really
get the heart at what's challenging in
metal learning problems
and what method that you might want to
use really depends on your use case and
and how much you care about these
positives and these negatives in your
particular use case
um i guess one thing i would recommend
is if you are doing classification and
you want to kind of just kind of
try out some one of these approaches i
think that non-parametric methods are
probably the easiest to get up and
running in practice
um
but beyond that i think that there's
kind of different trade-offs between
different methods
okay
yeah so my question is how is the matter
learning methods like black boxes
based work
kind of a problem we are working for
modern learning
yeah so for optimization based is uh
well for both these it's very
straightforward to apply them to
regression you just change the outer
loss function to be
like mean squared error or some other
regression loss function
and for mammal or optimization based
metal earners you will also change the
inner loss to be a regression based loss
as well and
beyond that you're kind of basically
done
learning in a regression problem it
really depends on how broad your
task distribution is but actually in the
original mammal paper for example we had
a regression task where different tasks
corresponded to different sinusoid
curves and we um we basically had a
family of sinusoids with varying phase
and varying amplitude so there's
basically two degrees of freedom um
within the task family and it's able to
learn with like five examples it
basically just has to identify
the sign curve from those five examples
and then it can actually
regress to the correct values of that
sign curve from the input so every task
is just one function right that's i
think
different from the classification
problems
yep
and that might be the problem when we
have a large number of k for a
non-parametric approach yeah so the
reason why it doesn't make scale to very
large k is for the same reason that we
don't use non-parametric methods with
really huge data sets um
to make a prediction with a
non-parametric method with like nearest
neighbors for example you have to search
over your entire data set and if you
have a very large data set then you have
to search over a large data set um so
it's going to be basically o of k if k
is small that's completely fine if k is
huge that's more of a challenge
and then asking i think a related
question is isn't the challenge with
scaling prototypical networks in n and
not k
since we can compute the distance from a
query vector to centroids and not the
distance
right okay so yeah so this is mostly
this comment is mostly corresponding to
um
to things like matching networks if you
use prototypical networks then
you're right and that it actually has to
do more with n
if n is very large then you'll have to
do more comparisons to the
to those prototypes but you can
essentially pre-compute the prototypes
which will make it easier to scale to
large tank
okay one more question from
yes i had a question about like present
homework setting right so we are using
this data set which has around 1600
classes and each task we sample around
five classes on it and then we are
assuming at test time in the real world
when you're using we'll also supply like
a support set which has a few number of
classes and then we'll use it to predict
on a query set but if you want to learn
uh a model that can predict all the
classes or like 500 classes or something
like that then do we
continue with the metal learning or the
few short learning setting because we
are still
perfect class we still have a very few
examples right or do we then move on to
the supervised learning setting
basically i'm asking
how do you
train a learner that can do
many classes but still having not too
many examples for class
yeah so that's basically exactly what
this case study was looking at where you
wanted not to just you basically wanted
to be able to produce
um
to be able to essentially kind of test
on all 200 classes even if you had only
trained on up to 150 classes
and with these non-parametric methods
it's actually quite easy to do this
because
for these base classes you've
essentially formed kind of
you formed prototypes for these base
classes that work well with all of the
kind of examples that you have and then
you can form additional prototypes with
your novel classes by passing in those
few examples and then averaging them to
produce and embedding uh
and then you just basically add in
prototypes and then when you classify
among the 200 classes you consider all
200 prototypes or kind of in this
specific case they're actually learning
multiple prototypes per class so it's
actually more than 200 prototypes but
it's easy to basically add these
prototypes and um
and kind of add them as you get more
classes and then do nearest neighbors to
to those prototypes
great
cool so now let's talk about some
applications which is maybe the most fun
part oh actually before we talk about
applications there's one more property
that i want to mention
um is uncertainty awareness so
one other thing that's nice to have in a
med learner is to reason about ambiguity
during learning
if you only have a few examples then
it may not be completely clear what the
correct function is even if you have a
lot of previous experience
it'd be nice to know like
if the few examples you have is enough
for you to make an effective prediction
or if the model thinks it needs more
data to be able to make an accurate
prediction
this is especially useful in active
learning settings where it's possible to
get more um to get more data in
reinforcement learning settings where
you can explore in different ways to
collect more data
and it's also useful for getting
calibrated uncertainty estimates which
might be relevant in um
in safety critical settings where you
want to know whether you trust your
model to make an accurate prediction
uh and it also leads to more principled
um kind of a more principled
interpretation to exactly what these
methods are doing within the framework
of bayesian graphical models
okay um and i'll drop up by talking
about some applications which i think is
always pretty exciting
and i'll just cover i'm just going to go
over four applications that illustrate
some of the things that you can do with
metal learning methods uh
this is by no means kind of a complete
survey of the applications that people
have looked at but
maybe hopefully get a taste for
what these methods are capable of doing
so in this first application the goal is
to do
uh imitation learning and uh imitation
learning is a really powerful framework
for training robots and and other
sequential decision making systems by
just telling them to supervise uh
basically doing supervised learning with
regard to some demonstrations that are
provided
but collecting a lot of demonstrations
for example on a robot is very expensive
because it requires a human to like tell
you operate the robot in a certain way
so
in this case the different tasks
correspond to manipulating different
objects that you want the robot to be
able to
uh
to manipulate um so for example
different tasks might correspond to
different objects that the robot is
holding and different containers that
you want the robot to place the
object into
in this case d train is going to just be
a video of a human doing the task
uh so our goal is to have the robot be
able to do kind of one-shot learning
from this video of a human
and d-test will correspond to a
tele-operated demonstration
and this basically tells it after you
see this training data
these are the actions that you should
take to complete the task
uh and then the model that's used in
this work is an optimization based model
it corresponds to mammal with a learned
inner loss function and the reason why
we need to learn this inner loss
function is we don't actually have like
a set of labels in this video of a human
um and if you're kind of interested in
learning more about that you can look at
the paper
and here's an example of what i was able
to accomplish at test time where
a person in this case
uh places a peach into this red bowl
then
shuffles the objects around and the
robot executes the policy that learned
in one shot
and they can figure out that
what it should do is
place the peach into the red bull
cool so this is one example of one shot
learning applied to
imitation learning
the next application that i'll talk
about is low resource molecular property
prediction where you want to be able to
predict the activities and properties of
a certain uh instance of a molecule with
only a few only a small amount of data
and this might be quite useful for low
resource drug discovery problems where
basically each data point requires
running like actually synthesizing that
molecule and running experiments with
that molecule
and so different tasks correspond to
predicting the properties and
activations of different molecules
and uh d training do tests correspond to
different instances i think of different
molecules and
potentially different kind of
circumstances
although i wasn't
it was difficult to find some details on
this in the paper
but if you dig a bit further it might be
a little bit more clear exactly what
drainage tests correspond to
and then the model in this case is
optimization based they tried a few
different variants of optimization based
models including mammal first order
mammal and almost no inner loop which
basically corresponds to mammal but
where you only update the last layer of
the model
uh in the inner loop rather than
updating the entire network
uh and then the base model that they
used with mammal was a gated graph
neural network so that they could
process the molecules
and these are generally the results that
they found
they found that in general mammal was
able to do better than first-order
mammal and
anal in each of these cases
and was also able to significantly
outperform
using k-nearest neighbors and
fine-tuning
on a variety of different held out
molecules
so this is pretty cool
the third application that i'll mention
is fuchsia human motion prediction uh
and the authors argue that this might be
useful for human robot interaction i
would also suggest that this could be
quite useful for autonomous driving if
you wanted to know whether a human will
cross the road for example or might
continue standing
at their particular location
different tasks correspond to different
human users and different motions that
they're performing
and the training data for each task
corresponds to the past k time steps of
motion
and the test data corresponds to the
future seconds of motion
essentially you want to be able to
predict the future based on the last
kind of snippet of time
kind of a hybrid of an optimization
based on a black box method where they
used mammal where they kind of first
fine tune with gradient descent and then
additionally use a learned update rule
on top of those fine-tune parameters and
then trained everything end-to-end
and then their base model was our
current neural network
and these are kind of qualitatively what
their results look like where
pamela is the kind of their proposed
hybrid method the top is the ground
truth this is the data this is their
kind of d train data right here and then
this is the prediction forward
and what you can see that is able to
kind of predict that this person will
keep on sitting down and is also able to
predict the kind of arm motions of the
human with
relatively decent accuracy
uh and they also looked at the kind of
mean
angle error with respect to the
prediction horizon ranging from 80 time
steps to a thousand time steps and are
able to find it kind of performs a lot
better than various multi-task learning
approaches and various transfer learning
approaches
okay and then the last application that
i'll mention is uh the gpt3 paper that
we didn't quite have time to go through
in the lecture on blackbox metal
learning
and in this case their tasks are quite
diverse
they correspond to things like spelling
correction simple math problems and
translating between languages and a
variety of other tasks
which i think is actually really cool
that they're able to trade it on such a
broad distribution of tasks
and they represented all of these tasks
as language generation problems
where kind of dtrain corresponds to
language
language that shows kind of the correct
answers for some of those problems
and d-test corresponds to kind of
what what the like what the future
language should look like
uh and here's kind of an example of how
you can write down simple math functions
spelling correction and translating
between languages
all as this language generation problem
the way they train this is they took
like a really just large amount of text
data from the internet from books um and
other language corpora
and d train corresponded to a sequence
of characters and d tests correspond to
the following sequence of characters
uh and the model is
what we could call like a black box my
learner was basically just this really
huge transformer model which
essentially corresponds to
uh different attention modules uh the
details on that don't matter too much
though uh in terms of understanding what
it's doing
and here are some some results from the
model so they could do one-shot learning
from dictionary definitions so the
uh the gray text essentially corresponds
to d-train and the block text
corresponds to d-test for this task
so the kind of training example is to
screen something is to swing a sword at
it an example of a sentence that uses
the word scree is
and then what the model produces is we
squeezed each other for several minutes
and then went outside and eat ice cream
uh there's also an example of c shot
language editing where you want to edit
language from horror english usage to
good english usage and you can give it
kind of all of this context of dtrain
that shows it kind of examples of what
it looks like to convert from port
english to good english
and find you can find that it can kind
of correct the sentence which said
i'd be more than happy to work with you
in another project to
i'd be more than happy uh to work with
you on another project
and also this sentence here which is
provide me with a short brief of the
design you're looking for and that being
that would be nice if you could share
some examples or projects you did before
to please provide me with a brief
description of the design you're looking
for
and that would be nice if you can
you could share some examples or
projects that you have done before
so it corrects kind of the language in a
few different cases
and this model is also trained on kind
of tasks that we wouldn't really
consider as huge help learning tests
which for example just correspond to
giving it a title and a subtitle and it
can generate an article on the topic
that you give it
okay so
uh yeah those are some examples of of my
learning applications and ways to
formulate different
uh different problems as meta learning
problems ranging from imitation learning
drug discovery motion prediction and
language generation
um
yeah and then that kind of
covers the goals uh
for this lecture
uh yeah hi professor thing so i have a
question so for the data set of omniglot
so we have different languages and
different characters so we want to
perform the method and so i'm wondering
so when when
what what we are trying to do in the
homework is to
sample
for example if we want to do
uh five ways when short learning we will
sample five characters from the same
language
and i'm wondering if there's any reason
that we want
the five characters to be in the same
language what i think we can also do is
to shuffle all these characters across
all the languages
and to choose five characters and do the
same method
yeah so in the literature people
actually most frequently shuffle
characters across languages just like
what you mentioned
um and that's a kind of yeah a
completely reasonable thing to do
uh
one reason why it could make sense to
not shuffle is if if for example it's
harder to discern characters from the
same language than the discerning
characters across languages
um
which will kind of better prepare you
for test time if you're only asked to
compare characters across uh kind of
within a language
um but yeah in general it makes a lot of
sense to shuffle across alphabets and
that essentially gives you more tasks
for better training
yes so and i also want to ask so i think
these two task distributions are
different right so whether you suffer
all these terms they are different
and so in practice so is there any
reason for example whether we should
consider to suffer or not shuffle
uh in general i think it makes sense to
shuffle the better training set because
it essentially just gives you more tasks
addition to the tasks that you get
within a language uh
so in general i think that in like
almost all cases it makes sense if you
have a very large number of alphabets
and you have plenty of data then it may
make sense to only consider tasks within
um
within a language because that will
be a kind of a harder task that's
reflective of a setting that you'll
realistically see at test time because
oftentimes with these systems you won't
be
what you care about most is like reading
someone's handwriting and you're not
going to see people like writing
characters in different languages most
frequently
um but in general in like almost all
cases i think it makes sense to to
shuffle the all of the characters across
languages yes so if if we can actually
shuffle all the languages and i'm
wondering so i think most of the uh the
data sets can be formalized into the
meta link case where for example we have
different classes and what we can do is
just to sample from these different
classes and to from this task
distribution and perform uh this kind of
feature learning task
yeah that makes sense
okay thank you so much
yeah i'm a little confused with the
dermatological disease diagnosis problem
set up
um so there are 150 base classes in 50
noble classes right so are the 15 novel
classes the handout classes
um
yeah so these 50 classes are held out
from
the uh
from the
from like training for training the
prototypical clustering network and the
prototypical network
so this is like a 200-way
um
k-short classification problem right
yeah so they they held out these five
these 50 novel classes and then at test
time they evaluated on all kind of on
the full 200-way classification problem
um and then these numbers are reporting
kind of the 200-way classification
prediction uh average across
base and normal classes average across
only the base classes in average across
only the novel classes
so during the training what is being set
to the network says you only have 150
classes
during the training um
the
images from those 150 classes are passed
into the network where you basically
um pass it into the network embed
uh
embed kind of a few examples from like
five examples from each of the classes
that you sample you compute the
embeddings and then you take new
examples from those image classes and
train it such that these prototypes
are
accurate on those new examples for the
classes that you sampled and then at
test time given the new ones you also
additionally embed those to get
additional prototypes
um
in this learned embedding space
and then when you do classification you
look at kind of whether it predicts it
for some of the existing prototypes or
some of the new prototypes
whether it's close like basically what
prototype is closest to
i didn't train you only
150 classes right
by doing testing
200 classes
yeah and it may be that they actually
i couldn't actually find this hyper
parameter in the paper but it could be
that they actually sub sample the 150
during training they made a sample only
like 50 or something or 20 um when they
do this when they kind of predict this
um
the downside is that meditating and
better testing aren't exactly matching
but it still can work reasonably well
just like how the siamese networks
worked well when you had the kind of
like uh a one class classification
during training and an n-way
classification during testing
thank you
yes i have a quick question about the
gbt3 uh example
so you listed a few examples at that
time
yeah
maybe the next slide
yes here
uh this is how uh the model is run at
inference time
but during change on during training
time the the metatrain examples adjust
the display the whole sentence into uh
two pieces and the first one is the meta
chain input and and the second one is
the mediterranean test
output and for the meta test
example
they did they mask the
output so that the model can predict the
output
yeah so different tasks correspond to
basically like language generation and
so
d train might be this and then d-test is
the top is like
generating this so it isn't fed in
this is like you could consider this as
like
y test actually sorry um
if you consider the black as like
y test
and this is like um
whoops this is like y train
and x is like
x is equal to nothing
so the task is to basically generate
white
um yeah i remember that
oh yeah so the test is basically
generate y train um so they're given y
train and then
uh
the goal is to generate y test which
corresponds to this block sentence
i see so there is actually no input to
the
to the model
there's no kind of x test input um
this kind of the aggregate of x test and
sorry x train or y train is equal to
d train and d train is passed into the
model uh because it's a black box model
i see so
if they used an optimization based uh
meta learning
would the setup be like similar to the
language model pre-training and
fine-tuning approach
yeah
where you would then fine-tune on like
all of this if you use an optimization
basement by the way
i see cool thank you
okay sounds good i think that was the
last question
have a good rest of your week
you